we spend a lot of time trying to change
other people there is after all so much
wrong with them they're selfish arrogant
bullying weak cold needy and so on so we
try to point some of this stuff out and
often meet with resistance denial or
sharing difference this can be very
agitating and hence renders us cross and
severe why won't people take our lessons
on board in our behavior we tend to be
making an implicit distinction between
two projects getting other people to
change and changing ourselves we know we
may have to develop in certain ways but
for now our focus is on altering others
we make an evolution in our own behavior
conditional on evolutions in other
people's we vow that we'll be nicer if
they're nicer that will be less strident
if they give up shouting however we're
prone to miss an important insight
changing how you behave to others can be
the fastest way to alter how others
behave towards you people tend to a
remarkable extent to mirror behavior if
someone is aggressive around them as
they become aggressive back if someone
is gentle they become soft in return if
someone acts wisely it'll draw any
latent reserves of wisdom out of the
audience
we're often in a paradoxical position of
advocating one kind of behavior or
making use of quite another
we might angrily suggest that someone
else calm down or we may bullying Lee in
fists to a person that they try to be
more empathetic we deserve sympathy
it's the agitation and anxiety of trying
to teach that can easily take us far
from the behavior we're advocating here
it bears to remember as saying often
falsely attributed to Mahatma Gandhi
though eminently useful nevertheless be
the change you want to see it captures
something key how sensible it may often
be to give up on teaching directly in
order to try to teach by example this
has one great advantage we can control
ourselves while it's remarkably hard to
exert any sort of direct control over
anyone else our disappointment with
other people
should be redirected towards exerting
control over the one thing we can
reliably command ourselves seeing us
exhibiting certain virtues has a
remarkable ability to inspire others in
- imitating us and even if change is not
immediate we can at least take pride in
the integrity of our position knowing
that we've had a strength and dignity
already to have start to become the
change we want to see
you